Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Russell,
save the throne and tell us that hello
at least. Thank you.
Alright. My name is David Flanagan, also known
as Rawkode, and I'm your host for today's
Rawkode live session. Today, we're taking a look
at OpenUnison,
a tool to bring identity management to Kubernetes.
Now, guiding us today on our journey of
OpenUnison,
is
my friend Mark. Hey, Mark. How's it going?
Good. Hey, David. How are doing? I am
doing very, very well. I get to sit
and play with some Kubernetes software. So I'm
That's always a good day. I'm I'm pretty
excited.
Why don't you say hello and tell us
a little bit about yourself, please?
Sure. So my name is Mark Borschin. I
am the CTO
and cofounder of Trello Security
and also the primary author of OpenUnison.
A little bit of
where you might have seen me around. I'm
usually in, like, the SIGAuth
or really anywhere in in the Kubernetes Slack
answering questions wherever I can.
I've made contributions to the Kate's documentation.
I added some contributions to, like, the dashboard
around impersonation.
Have made some contributions. So I've been I've
been around the community for quite some time.
Also, I'm gonna do some shameless self promotion
here.
Coauthor
of
Kubernetes,
an enterprise guide second edition.
Nice.
So
lot
of discussion
of advanced
Kubernetes topics. So authentication,
authorization,
global load balancing.
We get into Istio,
and then
we actually got rid of pod security policies
and replaced it with open gatekeeper.
So a a lot of very advanced
at the end, we also get into
building out a whole automated GitOps platform,
which is a lot of fun. So definitely
would encourage you to take a look at
the book on Amazon.
So
yeah. So that's that's all about me.
Alright. Let let me throw the low hanging
fruit question out then by default.
Sure. I think Kubernetes enterprise ready at the
box?
Right. Yeah.
You know, it it's actually a really great
question because
what
the there there's
I've always felt that there's a fundamental difference
between enterprise IT
and
service provider IT. So if you if you're
talking about folks like,
you know, Airbnb
and Netflix
and all of these great businesses there, you
know, Uber,
you know, they they they scale these massive
services,
and everything is focused on that service. Right?
Every every microservice that they build, if it's
Airbnb, ultimately, it's getting you to book the
road. Yep. You know, if it's Uber, it's
getting the ride or ordering the meal. If
it's Netflix, it's to watch the video. Everything
is focused on that.
Whereas in the enterprise
world,
you have a thing that the IT supports,
but the IT
is not the end product.
So if you're talking about a bank, for
example,
it's you know, you have to have IT.
It's incredibly important, but at the end of
the day, it's there to support the business
trend, you know, the the the money transactions.
You know, you talk about government agencies. We
do a lot of work in in different
governments,
and there are different departments that have different
missions, and IT is there to support them.
And so that ends up creating a very
siloed organization,
and then that siloed organization then translates down
to IT. So where in some place like
an Uber or another service provider,
you have everybody's working towards that same goal.
In in most enterprises,
you have silos
where
you as a manager are responsible for a
a thing. Right? Maybe it's maybe it's registration.
Maybe it's marketing, whatever that is, and you
have apps that support it.
But at the end of the day, your
bonus, what you get paid for is based
purely on what you're delivering.
And so you wanna minimize
the amount
of outside
interference,
outside risk.
Right? You wanna own as much of that
as possible.
And so most enterprises, you get a a
couple of phenomena where you get a lot
of replication.
You know? So, like, I've been I've been
preaching multi tenancy in Kubernetes since
01/13
was RBAC, I think, when RBAC.
I think that was RBAC.
You know, I I had a I had
a booth. Tremolo had a booth at the
first
KubeCon that was in Seattle when it still
fit in a hotel
ballroom,
you know, in in the lobby.
And I was talking to people about multitenant
Kubernetes, and they were looking at me like,
are you insane?
Just have another cluster.
You
know? And and that works great when you
have a lot of Kubernetes talent to manage
it.
You know, I don't know if you're aware
of this, David, but it's very hard to
debug Kubernetes clusters if they break.
You might have heard that once you've I've
got some experience there. Just a Yeah. Exactly.
You know, setting them up is pretty easy
these days. But if they break,
that's where things get really hard.
And most enterprises
just don't have the talent.
You know, the people don't have the knowledge.
So be like, oh, I spun up this
Kubernetes cluster, and it works great. And then
it breaks, and it's like, okay. Now what?
You know, if it's managed, it's a little
bit easier.
But,
you know so so
the when you get into enterprise,
you're dealing as much with silos as you
are with technology.
And in the Kubernetes world,
that tends to manifest itself in a couple
ways. One is multi tenancy.
You know, do I go with multiple clusters,
or do I go with,
know, many small clusters, which, you know, tends
to be people's first instinct,
or larger
small a smaller number of larger clusters.
And, you know, the the there's definitely been
a drift towards that multitenancy world, especially in
the last couple of years as as the
technology has improved
because you can provide that,
you know, that that silo.
And then the other thing is the this
move from
expecting Kubernetes to always be
interacted with by a CICD pipeline.
You know, in in in the services world,
it's always, well, I don't want people interacting
with clusters.
Okay. Well, that there is a lot of
value to that, especially in the microservices world.
But in the enterprise, you got a lot
of monoliths.
And
the people who own those monoliths,
if you tell them you can't log in
to the pod,
oh, you're
get to explain that one to the CIO
when there's a problem.
So it
it's developing the technology in a way to
deal with those silos. And that's what we
spend a lot of time with in the
book is what are the technologies that you
need to know to properly handle these silos?
Because what what I'll often see when I
go and I talk to either a government
agency or a company that's getting started with
even DevOps in general, not even just Kubernetes,
is they have this big grandiose idea of
a PaaS that they wanna build. And they
say, we're gonna build it, and it's going
to be a
product.
And
usually consultants who are saying, we're gonna build
a product for you.
And it's gonna be this product,
and it's gonna be, you know, choose from
column a, column b, column c, and that's
it.
And, you know, we're gonna maintain and manage
everything for you.
And when you get into enterprise,
you start running into all these little corner
cases and edge cases, and all of a
sudden, we the team that owns this
becomes
the people who are the roadblock.
And so they're the ones answering the question,
well, why hasn't this been done yet? If
I just had a VPC, I could do
this.
Well, we do it this way to make
your life easier, but you're not making my
life easier.
And so then it swings to the other
way where, like, you know what? We're just
gonna give you an empty cluster and be
done with it.
And whatever happens, that's totally on you. So
you get these pendulum swings back and forth.
Whereas the beautiful thing about Kubernetes, and this
one of the reasons I I I've always
loved it.
And and, you know, Kelsey Hightower nailed it
right on the head as the way he
usually does. It's a platform for building platforms.
So
you can go
kind of that PaaS route if you really
want to,
or you can go the open route or
you can go anywhere in between, and there's
a lot of flexibility there.
And so that's that's the approach we take
in the book is,
you know, the authentication, the authorization.
Yeah. When when we start talking about backups,
you know, it's not the sexiest thing in
the world, but you gotta do it.
Right?
And then even when we start getting into
GitOps, we start talking about, okay. Well, what
does multi tenancy look like in Kubernetes? Because
it ain't just Kubernetes.
You know, you've got something that's storing your
Git, right, especially if you're talking about GitOps.
You've got a GitOps controller, so you're talking
usually Argo or Flux. So what does that
look like in a multi tenant situation?
You
know? And then what are the policies that
you gotta think of, you know, like,
you know, change control boards. How do you
do cloud native change control boards? That's fun.
Or, you know, dealing with privileged access accounts.
And and so
so yeah. So we we get a note
to a lot of those very advanced enterprise
topics
that don't don't always come up when when
you're reading through the blogs.
Awesome.
That was a lot of information there.
And what I what I love is that,
you know, I I haven't spent a lot
of time in the enterprise environment. I, you
know, I haven't worked for a bank since,
what, 2012
maybe. So just, you know, before my my
Kubernetes days, before Kubernetes.
And a lot of the things you were
saying there kinda gave me little flashbacks, and
I said, oh, shit. Yeah. That was the
thing. And, like Is that why I saw
that cold look of terror on your face?
Well, yeah. But it's it's made me realize
that I have a lot of bias in
the discussions that I have these days because,
like you said, right, I feel from the
conversations that I have and the people that
I speak to at events is that the
dogmatic advice these days is to have lots
and lots of small clusters.
But when you think about it from the
enterprise perspective, like, that's a lot of authentication
batteries, and that's a lot of moving targets.
And that's the the I mean, even the
process
around handling that,
I can see why they would push towards
actually, no. I want large clusters because usually
they have the money as well to throw
at this high this kind of hardware build
or data center or even just give it
all to AWS. But, yeah, they would want
fewer clusters because it's less for them to
build process
and isolation around. So I never yeah.
You're flipping around a lot of the bias
that I had in my head just because
I haven't been working with those kind of
clients or those kind of people in such
a long time, but it makes a lot
of sense.
And get up, small eternity, like, for fuck's
sake. Like, that is such a beast as
well. Like, I mean, I don't even think
it was recent it was very recently, I
think, ArgoCD even supported
deploying it within a single namespace. It still
does. Like, it kinda does.
One
of the challenges with Argo
and I love Argo. Argo like, if if
I have a choice as to what I'm
gonna go with and I'm actually we might
even see a little demo with Argo today.
I like Argo because
coming from the enterprise world, I love my
GUIs. Yeah. I really do.
I know I'm in the minority in this
land, but I I I love a good
GUI. It makes my life easier.
You know, we we don't just do product.
We also do operations for some of our
customers.
And
I can tell you there have been many
a time where I have pulled up the
Kubernetes dashboard
securely
on this thing
and done something important,
and
it works great.
Yeah.
You know? So
I I do like Argo. The the issue
with Argo
with multitenancy that
that people miss is
Argo uses
the a cluster admin service account for all
of its synchronization.
And so if
you get if if you don't predefine
in Argo's RBAC
or in the project which objects can be
synced,
you could check-in, like, a
resource quota update as an example.
And Argo will sync it
because there's no RBAC
there. Well, these get ops operators, like, the
root and the cluster. I mean, the only
difference between them and Teller, which we all
kicked out really quickly, is that Teller has
a whole API. Teller. People could run from
their own machines, and GitOps doesn't. But still,
I mean, it it's written in your cluster.
Yeah.
I mean, there there are
so, like, Anthos actually does do it correctly.
Anthos
Centimeters, contact manager?
Does mean? Manager. Thank you. Where they actually
let you specify for each namespace
a different service account to use.
I think we've works or Flux does that
too.
What the Argo folks originally had a like,
they actually had a PR to do it,
and then they gave up on it when
application sets got merged because that actually solved
what they thought was the problem.
But
yeah. I I have also not run into
a lot of folks besides me who think
that Argo should be a multi tenant system.
I still tend to be a little ahead
of the curve on that one.
But
yeah. It's you know?
And and it's not just Argo. Right? I
mean, you think about a cluster.
Your cluster is more than just Kubernetes. Right?
You've got monitoring.
You've got you know, and and that monitoring
system has identities.
Mhmm.
You've got yeah. Even if you're just using
Prometheus and Grafana, you want everybody seeing it.
You've got,
you know, you've got your GitOps controller. You
might have GitLab running locally.
Right?
You know? And then
if you're running Istio, KeyOwl, he's got a
dashboard. Well, you need security around that.
You know, traffic has its own dashboard. You
probably wanna have some security around that. So
a lot of things end up piling into
this very, very quickly.
Yep. And and the hardest part is really
just
figuring out where the identities all fit together.
You know? So, like, you know,
I kinda like to talk about, you know,
supply chain security is the the big buzzword
now. Right? Like, it's s bombs.
And that stuff's really important. Don't get me
wrong. Yep. I've been beating that drum for
a long time,
but
identity management is a core piece of supply
chain security that a lot of people don't
think about.
I'm actually doing a workshop
with John Osborne from ChainGuard
at the B Sides Northern Virginia next Friday.
So if anybody's watching in DC,
would love to see you
about supply chain security.
And,
you know, if you think about
GitOps, you've got GitHub repos.
You've got your cluster.
You've got a GitOps controller.
Well, the GitOps controller has to talk to
your GitHub repo. What identity are you gonna
use?
You have a GitHub action that creates a
container
and pushes that container into a registry.
What identity are you gonna use?
Are you gonna use a static key? I
hope not.
You know, you've got and and then building
these things.
How are you gonna automate that? Because you
don't want to build that stuff manually.
And so the that that's all built in
to you know, identity management's a big part
of that that I
think a lot of people are missing when
when they talk about supply chain security. And
that that's really where where, you know, I'm
hoping to show you a little bit of
that today where where really our sweet spot
hits.
Well, you have no set. Supplies in security
five times, and we've had two VCs phone
in and offer each other. Yeah.
Alright. That's okay. They won't give me any
money.
No.
Identity is obviously a big thing. Multi currency
is is definitely you know, we have a
SEC dedicated to it now. We're trying to
improve this in the Kubernetes. I mean
Yep.
Is there software out there that can help
us with this chaotic problem within a Kubernetes
system? It's funny that you asked that, David.
Yes. There is.
So what does OpenUnison do? So I haven't
really talked a lot about what OpenUnison does.
So,
you know, the open source identity management, which
can mean a bazillion different things.
Our largest implementations are actually have nothing to
do with Kubernetes.
We started off Trello Security started off nice
Metallica shirt, by the way.
Kubernetes start or Trello Security started off as
a idea to simplify authentication
using reverse proxies.
So that should sound a little familiar.
And
the original idea was actually to use Kerberos
to eliminate
agents. And yeah. Yeah.
It failed miserably.
It was great.
And
we ended up growing up from there from
doing authentication
to doing just in time provisioning. So a
user logs in, and we automatically update
things, applications.
And then that grew into a larger workflow
engine, then we got into the user provisioning
game.
And so we we grew up from a
simplistic authentication
engine
to really powerful
identity system.
And so, for instance, I'm gonna be talking
in
a couple weeks at
kube con or Kubernetes Community Days DC
and then also at kube con in Detroit
about a public safety system we manage here
in the DC region, Washington DC in The
US for for all of our international friends,
that is built on top of Kubernetes.
But the system itself is actually has nothing
to do with DevOps or Kubernetes. It's all
about managing public safety systems.
So our our largest implementations are in kind
of the more generic enterprise identity world.
I just found this niche in DevOps and
Kubernetes and and said, you know, nobody else
is really doing a lot here. So it's
probably a place where I can create a
niche.
And so in
02/2016,
we came out with a namespace as a
service
utility
that allowed you to integrate any kind of
authentication
into Kubernetes
and allowed users to just log in, request
namespaces,
and and admins could approve it. And this
was
light years ahead of what people wanted at
the time.
And so we took that, and we slimmed
it down. We said, okay. Let's just create
a simple authentication portal, something that's quick and
easy to deploy.
Most of our users work with,
you know, an external identity provider.
So something like Azure AD and Okta or
an active directory.
We have a few GitHub users.
Most of our open source users
or or most of the GitHub users are
in the open source world. They're they're they're
not so much in the enterprise world.
And we we we always strive to make
it as simple as possible to deploy with
requiring
as few external dependencies as possible. So we
we went through kind of an interesting journey
where and and we're kinda going full circuit
is we started with a
container that you would launch that would do
all the work and deploy it because this
was still Helm two territory.
Then we created an operator when that's what
all the cool kids were doing. Yep. And
that that helped, but it was still kind
of bit of a bear.
And then as we're getting more deployments, we
found that most of the problems people were
having had absolutely nothing to do with OpenUnison
and with certificates, load balancers, host names, IPs.
And so
we we kinda took a step back,
and we created Helm charts to simplify it.
Yes. But we ended up having, like, three
Helm charts because
anybody who tells you there's eventual consistency in
Kubernetes is lying to you.
I know it's another controversial
one that a lot of people don't agree
with me with, but if you've ever had
to deal with a custom admission controller, you'll
know what I mean.
And so
we ended up saying, okay. Let's
let's simplify that even further. So we we
keep created the OU control command
to really automate as much as we could.
And so that that was one side of
it. We said, okay. Let's create this portal
that's really simple to deploy.
The other half of it that we wanted
to do was we wanted to make it
so that you didn't have to distribute anything
for authentication into your cluster. So we didn't
want you to have to download a kubectl
configuration file.
We didn't want you to have to prepublish
configuration files. That's one of the harder things
with a lot of OpenID Connect implementations
is,
you know, they'll they'll give you a kube
config file or you can use the the
great
OIDC
kube control plug in, but you have to
preconfigure it with some stuff. We didn't want
you to have to do any of that.
We want everything to be be prepopulated for
you.
So our first version,
there's just a little button you click that
says copy my kube control command, and we
set up your entire kube config via kube
control, including all your certificates.
So everything is trusted off the bat.
A lot of developers didn't love that. It
worked well if you had, like, a a,
you know, jump box, god forbid.
But, you know, developers
wanted to run kube control locally. They didn't
really wanna have to do this copy and
paste thing.
And so then we developed the OU login
plug in, which you just give it the
host name of your OpenUnison,
and it automatically logs you in. You don't
have to have a preconfigured
Kube control configuration.
The other
priority we had was short lived tokens.
We really wanted to make it so that
those tokens didn't live more than a minute
and to make it transparent to users because,
you know, I mean, that the great thing
about tokens is is that they they scale
really well. The bad things is if you
lose it, bad things are gonna happen.
That that's that's a real risk when it
comes to
bearer tokens.
So and by the way, we here. Woah.
Yeah. And we we we get in the
book.
We get into an obscene amount of detail
as to how that works and why. And
it's actually a free chapter. So if you
check out the
the GitHub repo, so no registration, nobody knows
who you are. You just download the PDF
for that chapter.
But
yeah. So,
you know, we we we wanted to make
it so that you could very easily use
short lived tokens transparently,
and we want to make GUIs easier. Like
I said, I love the dashboard, so we
wanted to make it easy to securely use
the dashboard.
I'm I'm a big proponent.
And in fact, again, in the book, I
spent an entire chapter on the security of
the dashboard
because it's really important to understand
how that security works when people say, oh,
the dashboard's insecure. No. It's not insecure.
It's insecure how people deploy it. You know,
you're using Kube control port forward or you're
using Kube control proxy. Yeah. It's insecure.
You know, you give it an RBAC, you
know, a privileged RBAC credential. Yeah. It's insecure.
But, you know, you use it properly with
the reverse proxy.
No less secure than anything else,
especially you had multifactor authentication to it.
You know, you're in good shape. So
yeah. So,
you know,
the the the real benefit of using OpenUnison
is just being able to quickly get into
clusters,
being able to integrate your enterprise
authorization because most enterprises have some kind of
authorization system.
You know you know a product does its
job real well when a massive
public company that does identity management
uses our little open source project for integration
with their Kubernetes clusters.
So, you know, that that told me that
we were probably on the right track for
what how to do it.
So I know I've spent a lot of
time talking. You wanna get in some tech?
Yeah. I'm excited. I I wanna I do
So yeah. So you've got a few clusters
ready to roll. Right? I do. Let's cover
the what have I prepared in advance?
The answer, as always, is pretty much nothing.
Yep. So today, we have the OpenUnison documentation.
This is available at openunison.github.io.
The GitHub repository is available at github.com/tromolosecurity/openunison.
And we have
a couple of clusters today, kindly provided by
our friends at Civo. So I have three
Civo clusters.
OpenUnison one, OpenUnison two, OpenUnison three.
We have a Docker desktop in Manikip, but
they're not as fun. So
what's on these clusters? The answer is
nada.
All I have done is use simplified
app management to display engine x ingress with
a load balancer. So these are fresh, clean,
happy to be OpenUnison's
clusters.
Sound good?
Sounds good.
Alright. So in the documentation here, we have
some nice bullet points telling us that OpenUnison
simplifies access and increases security to things that
all Kubernetes clusters need.
And
let's get do we just go jump straight
into deploying the syndication portal? Is that step
one, Mark? Yeah. Let's rock. Alright.
Okay.
Prerequisites,
ingress controller.
Check.
Site specific configuration.
This is something we'll need to do at
some point, I guess.
And well, Danny, to install all your controllers,
I'll look at it.
As you go through, I I kinda wanted
to give people a a heads up as
to what you're gonna do
and then go through all the the individual
steps.
And you're saying we can do all this
in thirty five ish minutes?
Yeah.
Quicker? Usually, I hope quicker than that. Yeah.
Alright. Okay. So I'm gonna skip the ingress
controller. I deployed NGINX. Good.
We're gonna deploy the Kubernetes dashboard.
Nice. Let's do it.
I'm just trusting.
Yeah. That looks relatively safe.
Yeah.
Yeah. We'll go with that.
So site specific configuration.
So this for our helm chart. I see
there's some values that yaml mentioned here that
we can customize. So let's click on that,
do a bit of a copy.
And I'll just leave this here for
as we need it.
And then we can deploy the portal.
Alright. Let's Oh, you skipped a step.
If
you if you scroll up or nope. Go
back to I'm just gonna add that. Oh,
okay. Gotcha.
Alright.
So
did I miss the step? Yeah. You did.
The the three boxes there,
how to customize
your default values.
Alright. Okay.
So
okay. I should read the docs, shouldn't I?
Sometimes I just get I can't read the
way in this. So
okay. So the first thing says, do we
want to enable impersonation?
You wanna give us the do you wanna
give us the TLDR in these options?
Yeah. Sure. So OpenUnison
will work whether you're running a on prem
cluster
where you can change the
the
API server
configuration flags
for OpenID Connect. If you're if you're running
an on
excuse me. If you're running an on prem
cluster, that's always what I recommend as as,
you know, bypass
the the impersonation proxy.
But if you're running in a managed cluster
where those that's not a possibility, like Civo,
AKS,
you know, GKE, any of these other ones,
enable the impersonation proxy. And what that does
is it launches a Kubo IDC proxy
that acts as a impersonating proxy.
So kubectl actually interacts with that proxy,
and then that proxy interacts with your API
server on the user's behalf using Kubernetes impersonation.
And then, like, if you look in the
audit logs, it'll actually say that, oh, this
this action was performed,
you know, by David via impersonation.
Okay. So you're keeping all that information in
there.
The network, this is where
people tend to get hung up the most,
mostly because it's the first thing you tend
to deploy inside of a cluster is your
authentication system a lot of times.
And so they they haven't quite
wrapped their heads around how Kubernetes and networking
works.
And so here's
you know, it's just three settings. Yeah. What
do you want your host names to be?
It's just the it always has to point
to the load balancer for your cluster
or more specifically for your for your ingress
controller.
Mhmm. And then finally, authentication.
Inside of the values dot YAML, you're gonna
find commented blocks
of all of the different authentication mechanisms.
You uncomment one of them. You go through
the steps in the documentation,
and
you go ahead and configure it.
You know, we try to we try to
make the documentation
as
single path as possible.
So even though you diverge a little bit.
So, like, in the network session section,
you've got the OpenUnison host, dashboard host, and
API server host.
You're gonna want those to point to
your load balancer. So as an example, I'm
a big fan of nip.i0
for development.
So if you just did, like, katesi0dot,
you know, ip.nip.i0
or whatever you wanna call it.
Okay.
You need to put the IP address in
You have to put the IP address in
there. Yeah.
It doesn't have to be dashes, but you
could do that.
And then the next one's gonna be your
dashboard host.
And then the last one is the
host name for your impersonation proxy.
So does it work with dots? I thought
it had to be dashes.
No. It works fine with dots. I actually
prefer to do dashes only because it looks
more
real, I guess.
But, yeah, it'll work perfectly fine either way.
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure that I have not
messed this up, and we'll make sure this
resolves to the IP address that we expect.
Yep. So
perfect. Right. Now
most enterprises will usually have, like, a wildcard
cert that they're using. So you can configure
this to do that. We actually include a
mini cert manager
that will generate all self signed certs for
you. So if you're just getting started, you
just wanna get the thing up and running,
you don't have to have, like, cert manager
deployed ahead of time. We're gonna we're gonna
generate those certificates all for you. Yeah. I
guess it's important for people to know that
when you use a service like that or
net is that Let's Encrypt will not give
you a certificate for those domains. So you
have to do something else.
Exactly.
Okay.
So let's the network embed looks fine to
me now. Right? It's good to me. Yep.
Okay. The OU, I'm I'm assuming we don't
have to tweak this. This is just for
the x five. Yeah. I mean, if you
really wanted to, you could.
Alright. I'll tell you what. Well, at least
the
I'll go with the academy. There we go.
Yeah. And they're all self signed certs. And
Tremolo. Okay.
We don't need to configure the image, cluster
name, impersonation, we I would actually change the
cluster name because we're gonna talk about multicluster
in a little bit. So, like, I usually
call the first one, like, control plane or
something like that so that you know it's
your
it's your primary.
Okay.
I just call OpenUnison one to match the
cluster name from Excel.
We're using JetStack's
OIDC proxy. Although, looks like you've got your
own build of it. Is that tweaked in
some way? Yeah. So we took over
maintenance of the OIDC proxy
about
a year ago, I think. Yeah.
JetStack,
you know, it's a JetStack created a great
project.
We found that there were a couple of
things that
were missing that that we found
would be really helpful.
And then we also wanted to
just get it to the point where it's
being maintained and actively tested and updated.
All the libraries are updated. So one thing
that we take great pride in at Tremolo
is making sure
that whenever we release software and you look
at those known vulnerabilities,
it's as close to goose eggs as possible.
And in fact, we have continuous
scanning
of our containers. Everything's built on Ubuntu. So
whenever
Canonical releases patches to CVEs,
that automatically triggers rebuilds.
So
we're we're constantly pushing out fresh versions.
Alright.
Okay. Let's run through the rest of these
values fail then and get this thing deployed.
Nothing here in the dashboard looks like looks
like it needs changing.
The the only time you really need to
change that is if you have a custom
deployment to the dashboard or
the if you use the helm chart for
the dashboard, you gotta adjust a couple of
those values.
Okay. I'm assuming we leave this false to
your cert manager. True.
We just use the Kubernetes basic cert stuff,
I guess. Yeah. It
originally,
we thought it would be cool to use
Kubernetes on built in certificates
so that everything was automatically trusted except we
found, a, it wasn't automatically trusted.
And, b,
on x on, you know, managed clusters,
you often couldn't even get access to it.
Like, that private key wasn't there, like EKS
and AKS and whatnot. So
we just always disable it now.
And then
I think that you yep.
So
our on the enterprise side, active directory and
OIDC are definitely our largest
implementation base. Mhmm.
I always thought SAML would be more popular.
It never was.
People have just skipped SAML and seem to
go straight to OpenID Connect.
Yeah. SAML was the thing for, like, two
minutes, and then it just everything's like A
little longer than two minutes.
You know, it
what really kinda changed things was
the pandemic, to be honest,
because
that's when organizations
really shifted from
using their own on prem active directory federation
services, which is only SAML,
to
Azure AD, which supports both SAML and OpenID
Connect.
And because
you know, SAML's really great in in really
segmented networks because you don't have that back
channel communication that you have with OpenID Connect.
But in
when your identity provider is on the Internet
and it's Azure AD or a doctor,
who cares?
Okay.
That's fair. That's fair. I'll I'll I'll buy
that.
But, yeah, it it it it definitely
has never been as popular as I thought
it was gonna be. Yeah.
Alright. So we're we're gonna go with GitHub.
Right? Yep. Mhmm. K.
So that is the GitHub application?
Yep. So you're gonna go into your either
an organization or you can do it on
your personal settings and create a a auth
app.
Alright. I'm not sure if I can I
can't remember it? Flashes secret and stuff, so
I was gonna do it. Is it okay
to do on on screen?
I mean, I would just delete it afterwards.
Alright. Okay.
You know, people in chat or who are
watching live, please be good neighbors.
Yeah. One day, I'm gonna learn to stop
flashing tokens on a stream.
Alright. Let's go. Waff apps.
New.
Open.
Unison.
Rawkode.
And is this gonna be my net IP?
So that's gonna be the
if you go to your network section, it's
gonna be OpenUnison h h t t p
s, your OpenUnison host value
slash auth slash GitHub.
Auth slash GitHub.
And we're I'm I'm only telling you what's
already in the docs, so
you're you're not getting anything secret here.
Alright. So you got that client ID. That
can go into the values dot YAML. And
I'm assuming it's like a secret and a
secret. No? Maybe?
You're actually just gonna put the secret in
a file,
and then OU control will create your secret
for you.
Alright.
And you got the client ID in there?
Okay. Cool. It's there.
Other policies, I'm assuming we can skip that.
You can skip that for now. I mean,
we give you a lot of
customization
points. And then, you know, if we have
time to get into namespace as a service,
that's where you get into that. But you
don't need a data. The the thing with
OpenUnison is we say, only
implement infrastructure you need for what you're gonna
do.
So
because
the authentication
proxy doesn't have any
asynchronous
workflows
or self-service in it. We don't make you
to deploy a database. We don't make you
deploy anything for
notification.
So we wanna keep it as simple as
possible. Only deploy what you need for what
you're gonna do.
Got it. So that looks good? It does.
And then go
ahead and create
a file
with your GitHub secret in it.
Might as well display
Russell's comment just now.
Alright.
Safe. Nobody got it.
Cool.
Alright.
And so you already deployed
that.
So you gotta download
almost.
You gotta download the OU control command for
whichever platform you'd like.
Is this m one ready?
Yes. It will
I'm assuming you have Rosetta installed. I do.
Yeah. Okay.
Dash o o u c t l.
No length.
Oh, it must be a redirect. So dash
f f.
That's weird.
What if you just do a w get
on the ah, where'd you go? Was just
making sure I could actually write
oh, no. Wait. I'm just being Oh, you're
in the can are you in a container?
No.
I've just got my
parameters the wrong way around.
Failed to receive data to disk.
Alright. I'll do it in my home directory.
Maybe that temp just has or is it
small or for rate to fail? It may
just be Honestly, I just use w get.
Oh, yeah. It's small or
Yeah.
I like w get because it gives you
a little progress bar.
Alright. I'm old school like that.
Oh, I can't type. Alright. Okay.
User local.
Is that
hate typing my password on screen.
At least that one, we can't see. I
know. But I was doing it once on
a stream with Alex Ellis, and sudo crashed
as I was typing. And then my password
was just all over the
Of course, I mean, I I don't I
don't duplicate any passwords, and it's only my
local machine password. So it's not a big
deal. But still Now I haven't done it
yet, but do you have the Touch ID
keyboard?
So
I I type on a good keyboard. But
Oh, you've got the mechanical.
Okay. But I keep this little thing to
the side purely for thumb,
for my fingerprint. Gotcha.
I I haven't done it yet, which is
weird because I live by Touch ID.
But
you can set up sudo
to use Touch ID on on Mac.
Nice.
Need to look into that in one day.
You can also I I know I can
do it on my watch, but then I
always find it weird while we're tapping it
as well, which is
anyway, we're taking our rest. Let's let's get
back on track. So we've got all your
control. Progress?
So, yeah, so you've got all your control.
You're ready to rock and roll. Alright. So
we're going to install,
point it to
our secret file, and then the YAML file.
Yep. So
the YAML file is our values. Right? And
the secret file is my please don't copy.
Exactly.
Please don't copy me dot text. I think
I called it.
Yes. No. Don't getting there. Well, no. That's
Don't copy
me, please. I should've called it Yeah. I
seem to remember there was a please in
there.
Alright. So
is this going to create a Kubernetes secret,
web our secret our client secret for the
GitHub app and to help deploy
into our cluster?
Exactly.
Oh, no database section.
Check out the values.
I have a
oh, I know why. Shoot. Okay. See where
it says enable provisioning is true?
I gotta fix this. I was messing with
it.
Kids, don't mess with the website right before
the
the demo.
It's in the OpenUnison section. Yep. Yeah. So
change that to false. And then on the
next line,
change that to true.
Go ahead and run. I gotta fix that
right after this. Here we go. Yeah. So
I decided not to tell people to make
the secret because what people were doing was
they would do echo secret
into base six you know, pipe base 64.
And so everybody would be telling me, it's
not working. It's not working. It's not working.
I keep getting access to nine. Well, yeah,
because echo adds that that slash m at
the end.
And so I was like, you know what?
I'm just gonna take that out and and
and I didn't wanna have it on the
command line because I hate having
secrets as command line parameters.
So
so yeah. So we we actually embed Helm
into this command.
So it's just running the Helm charts, but
the nice thing is is that it's paying
attention
to
the cluster. Like, it's waiting for things to
finish. It gives a little pauses. I I
I love Sivo to death for especially for
my testing clusters. I do find that when
you're very heavy on watches and you're very
heavy on CRDs the way we are,
because everything is configured through a custom resource.
It
I've I've found Cboe to be a little
more
persnickety
than most other clusters
I've worked with.
Okay.
So you said, just while we're in, everything
is configured by some sort of custom resource.
So you can get up Pretty much. Entire
OpenUnison
deployment then as well? Oh, yeah.
Yeah. We've got
we actually have we haven't formally released it
yet, but we have a Argo version that
uses waves.
So you create the secret manually
and you point Argo
to
the special repo that's just a, you know,
just a sync of all the correct repos,
but with the wave
not label.
What's the other thing besides the label I
can put on object? Thank you. Annotation. I
know Kubernetes. I promise.
With the correct annotations with the right waves,
and so that way, you don't use the
OU control command,
at least for that instance.
So
this is
running.
Yeah. I'm gonna do some investigation.
So
It's a it's a slightly larger pod,
and it's just pulling I think it's coding
images. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That that that's strange because
I mean, that CUBO IDC proxy
is only 45 megs.
The Orchestra one's pretty big.
So, hopefully,
think
it I think it gives up after
a thousand tries.
Alright. Structured that that top is, which is
weird because
oh, you're you're you're probably running your cluster
cluster in
in Europe.
You know what? I don't even think I
paid attention to where I stuck this thing.
Not that it should matter because it's all
coming from Docker Hub.
Well, it doesn't tell you a region by
default. Where where did I put it?
I'm looking in your bottom left.
Oh, yeah. London. Yeah.
So I don't know. Maybe
maybe they just don't have good networking over
to Docker Hub from London.
Yeah.
Take a look at the events.
Is there
a Let me
Is there something that's not mounting? Oh, we're
missing Oh, there we go. Secret volume,
orchestra not found. Do a k get nodes
or k get secrets?
Yeah.
Okay. Take a look at your
there's a pod that's called OpenUnison
operator. Take a look at that.
Did we miss something?
Or I'm sorry. Look at the logs
for that pod.
Yeah. Finally. Just gave up.
Oh. Alright.
Where
oh, interesting. It had a problem
talking to
see see, this is why I mean where
it'll it'll sometimes have weird issues with
civo's API server. Okay. Let's do this. Just
go ahead and rerun the command again.
So one thing about the o u control
command is it's designed to be rerunnable.
So if something does fail, you can always
rerun it with the exact same parameters,
and it will
check to see if thing so, like, the
secret already exists.
So let's say
so let's see here. There's Orchestra secret source.
So right now, it's redeploying
that.
Oh, there we go. Yeah. There we go.
Okay. Cool.
So, like, one nice thing about OU control
is, let's say you're just doing an update
to your configuration,
but you're not changing the secret. You don't
need to have that secret file.
It'll say, oh, the secret's already there. I'm
not even gonna you know, unless you specify
a new secret to rotate it, I'm just
gonna leave it alone. Like, it it builds
some of the intelligence that an operator would
wanna have a human operator would wanna have
during deployment. There we go.
Alright. I'm assuming that's gonna be much quicker
now since it's Yeah. I mean, you're already
running. So it's
we're just waiting for it to get to
the point where it's
ready one one.
There we go. Now the old one. And
you can see, like, it's saying, oh, I'm
gonna wait until there's just one pod because
that's the number of images I want. I
don't wanna release control
until
we're at that point. So we're gonna wait
for things to to terminate.
It's waiting for the eventual consistent to be
consistent. Right? Exactly.
You know, which is something that, like, Helm
doesn't do. Right? Helm
doesn't
you know, if it fails because of a
webhook, it just fails,
which is where my whole eventual consistency is
a lie comes from. Yeah. I have that
all that problem all the time. I mean,
admission admission controllers are definitely a problem, but
finalizers are the ones that really get on
my my nerves.
Although, I had fun this morning with a
customer with pod disruption budgets.
That
that that really caused some heartburn.
Combination of pod
disruption budget and
having to rebuild a cluster that had lost
its
authentication token.
Oops.
I'm gonna try and speed this up a
little bit.
There we go.
When in doubt, force.
Yep.
And so the next thing it's doing so
what you've done right now is you've deployed
the Orchestra pod.
So that's got a very simple baseline configuration.
Okay. And then yeah. And here we go.
So joys of webhooks.
Let's go ahead and run it again. It
should be much quicker this time because I
was just waiting for the certificate.
We probably had that too quickly.
But
I forgot what I was gonna say. What
were you talking about before the
oh, admission controllers. Yes.
And and finalizers and pod disruption budgets.
Yeah. I mean, I love admission controls. I
mean, we use admission controllers because we've got
very complex
CRs
that
just can't be
can't be
they just they can't be
validated just through schema.
Like, even the new whatever the the new
schema validation language in '25.
You know, there's that new scripting language
that you can embed into
your schema for CRs in one dot 25.
It's not Turing complete.
Yeah. I I can't, yeah, I can't remember
the name of it, but the idea is
is that
I think it's a beta in 25. It's
either an alpha or beta in 25. It's
not GA.
But
it it lets you it gives you a
little more
capabilities
around validating schema
rather than just open API.
I'll
try one more search before I give up
on it, but I'm gonna have to look
into the Combiner. That's what it is. Or
no. Combiner is the name of the release.
There is in there
I cannot remember the name of it for
the life of me.
Then again, I couldn't remember when annotation was,
so I don't know why anybody would listen
to me.
I thought it went to '25 as a
beta.
I don't know. We'll find out later. And
probably that's have to be honest, I've just
not paid attention to the 01/25 release really.
I I
because I've not upgraded the cluster to it
yet, but that is my next plan. Gotcha.
So
alright. Let's get back over to our
dogs
and
here. It's
shutting down.
I'm still trying to delete that pod.
I'm assuming it doesn't respect the sec term
or it's just not got a program. It
does. It's just the
it
it's cleaning up itself.
I do find that it takes a while
to
to shut itself down.
Although this does seem to be taking longer
than usual,
usually within about thirty seconds.
Maybe I should've
sprung for some bigger nodes.
What what size did you go with?
Four CPUs, eight gig around. Nice and bad.
That's what I've been using.
Yeah. We've got a probe failure for check
alive.
I mean, it's unhealthy. It should be dying.
Why
won't you die?
Oh, there we go. Alright. Now I just
just needed to restart before it finally Yeah.
It looks like something was going on there.
Yeah. I've gotta spend a little more time.
I I figure Civo's probably exposing
an underlying issue that I need to to
look at when it comes to the way
that we're
oh, but it's there. It's waiting a few
seconds. So it waits about ten seconds.
Alright.
So Looks like we're in business.
So if you take a look at your
pods
actually, you should be able to just log
in. So, obviously, there's no it's a self
signed cert.
Yep.
So you gotta
let us see
see all your unmentionables.
I'm pretty sure I used that org. Yeah.
You used Rawkode Academy as your authorizing
organization.
Cool. So you're in. So now you click
on that dashboard,
and
you'll be in. You won't be able to
see anything because you still have to enable
some RBAC policies.
So, yeah, if you look at the bell
in that upper right hand corner, you'll you'll
see bunch of RBAC errors. And if you
look at your little human on the right
hand side because you're using impersonation,
it'll actually have your GitHub username. I wrote
that.
So, yeah, if you grant now the nice
thing is is you can grant RBAC based
on
your GitHub works.
So you're not granting RBAC directly to a
user. So if you go back to the
documentation,
I actually have a example in there.
So scroll
you actually, on the right hand side, see
where it says GitHub RBAC bindings?
So you wanna copy that and just change
the group from Tremblay security owners to,
you know,
whatever you want, really.
Alright.
So
we're saying all owners
here get cluster admin and the cluster.
Yep.
I call this RBAC.
So now you go back to your dashboard,
and you can see all the errors are
gone. Man. Maybe not. I may have to
log in back in?
No. Click on the
that little bell thing again.
Is forbidden.
Interesting. Go back to the main
OpenUnison
screen.
And then in the upper left hand corner,
you'll see your name Rawkode. Click on that.
And I actually can't read it. It's really
fuzzy.
But do you see Rawkode
I don't see anybody called Rawkode owners. That's
probably the problem.
So if if you wanna
just be
Also that You wanna just do Rawkode slash
or my you know, any one of those.
Would that work? Just Rawkode? No. It has
to be slash. So slash nothing means you
wanna let the entire organization in.
Alright. Let's just do the cluster team because
I I trust me.
Is that is that a smart move? No.
So okay. Now it's all gone. So now
you are, in fact, a cluster administrator,
and you can do everything
to your heart's content that the dashboard lets
you do.
Stuff like the terminal works beautifully.
You wanna terminal into
things.
So
and then we've got all sorts of little
controls in the back, like, you know, if
you log out of the main portal
and
they'll they'll
break you out of this. So you can't
leave the the main portal.
You know, you can't leave the main portal
but still get into the dashboard.
You know, most enterprises have policies around things
like idle time out,
stuff like that.
And then if you wanna access your cluster
directly using kubectl,
you go back to that main screen.
You click on home,
see that Kubernetes token.
Wow. I think my Internet fast.
Struggling.
Well, I do stream on a fry a
five g connection, which is usually pretty solid.
Really?
Yeah.
That's impressive.
The fiber company for this building wanted an
extortionate amount of money, and I said, no.
I'll go with five g. And I actually
get, like, 500, six hundred meg down and,
like, 300 meg up. Well, from what I
real I think y'all Europeans are much harder
on your telcos for marketing nonsense than we
are here in The States.
I think here as long as it's not,
you know, one g accounts as five g.
There we go. There it is. Okay. So
it took a second. So now you've got
a kube control command and a Windows kube
control command.
And if you actually look, there's a little
set of boxes next to the word kube
control command. It makes it a lot easier.
And so you take that. And what I
would do is don't use the same
kubectl configuration
so that way you don't lose your
you know, potentially overwrite
your existing context.
It's alright. I'm using Kubi. So all of
my Oh, okay. They're all different files. So
Gotcha.
Well so yeah. So what's gonna happen is
you paste that in, and it's going to
generate
a kube control configuration
file using the kube control command. So it's
gonna go to whatever. So now you can
see if you do a kubectl get nodes.
Notice.
Yeah.
There you go.
You now have access to everything.
And so
the
left the phone down here.
The
yeah. You're right now going through that that
Kubo IDC proxy, and and the reason we
use that is because
Kubernetes again?
There is the Who am I making is
that a plugin?
That is a plugin. I I
think the API was included in '25, but
they haven't added anything to kubectl yet.
I would say do something you're not allowed
to do, but you're a cluster admin. I
know. I've got everything. So So you've got
everything.
But the nice thing is is that you
didn't set up any certificates.
You didn't set up any host names. It
all just worked.
Now really cool thing is, why don't you
set up a watch on, like, kubectl get
pods or whatever?
Well,
could you help me understand what actually happened
here?
Yeah. So Is this set up as service?
You drew two owl two circles, and then
you had Kubernetes.
So what happened was
if you look at your if
you go back in your
command history to the actual command,
it's gonna be this big giant thing.
I'll just scroll up.
Yeah. There you go. So what we're doing
is
we're actually using all existing
control configuration
commands. Like, the you're doing the you didn't
download anything to actually run this.
And so the idea here is that we
wanted it so that you didn't have to
deploy anything to access clusters other than kubectl.
So what do we do? We set the
server up with the correct host name. Now
in this instance, that host name will be
our API our API proxy. So you're not
talking directly to the Cboe API server. You're
talking to the Kube OIDC
proxy.
We set up the certificate for it.
We set up
the OIDC
configuration,
so where the issuer is, the certificate for
the issuer.
We and then we went ahead and also
set up your
initial ID token and refresh token.
So now
you can just go to your heart's content,
and kubectl is gonna continuously refresh that token
until
one or two things happen. Either you idle
time out
or if you log out of OpenUnison,
it will end your session.
So the security folks in enterprises love that,
that there's a way to actually kill a
session in within about a minute.
And that's just by revoking the refresh token.
Right? Yep. And then, like, let's say, you
know, David's gotta be walked out for whatever
reason.
Know? He's gotta be fired again. Yeah.
It it you know, it's Tuesday. Right?
You know, you go in and the session
is stored as CRs, so you just delete
all of David's sessions, and within a minute,
those tokens are gonna stop working.
So
I think it's called I think if you
do, like, a kubectl get o I d
c dash sessions and OpenUnison,
you'll see them.
O I d c
dash sessions.
Yep. So you've got a bunch of sessions
open. You delete those,
and then within about a minute, your your
token will become useless.
So as an operator, you wanna you wanna
kill somebody's sessions.
Alright. Need to look at what it is.
Sure.
Now I am the first person to say
you should never store anything sensitive
in a
CR.
I break that rule here because this is
all encrypted,
and RBAC
protected. So if somebody has this,
unless they also have the decryption key,
they don't have access to anything.
Yeah.
I think it is binary encrypted and then
base base encoded.
No. I don't know. I see the equals,
and I think maybe base Yeah. The that
one's just base 64
encoded, I think.
But
that has to match up with stuff in
the encrypted ID token and the access token.
Nice.
I you know what? There's there's so many
benefits from storing stuff and custom resources because
I get to hook into all of the
tooling
that I already know.
Yeah.
And I I just think this is a
really, really sleek way of doing it. This
is very cool. It
works really well.
We used to do it in a database.
And
back when we first started it and once
CRs became a thing I remember when I
first said, you know, how would I store
custom information
in Kubernetes?
This is this is before CRs were even
available.
And I was like, you know, would I
just talk to etcd directly? And they're like,
no. And I go, why? He goes, you
know, you know, are you some kind of
masochist? You wanna talk to etcd directly?
You you enjoy pain?
And so the the CRs, I think, are
are really going to
become a big part of what makes Kubernetes
your
your data center operating system rather than just
a
pod control management system, a container control management
system. I really hope that the API machinery
team add some sort of sensitive or encrypted
label for custom resource fields so that even
that can be handled
by the API server. But I mean, I've
I've got a whole rant on secrets management
in Kubernetes.
But now the cool thing is
a lot of people don't like what we
did with
copying and pasting that token. Mhmm.
And so
if you go back to our documentation,
there is a
or I don't know. Do you have
a crew installed? The crew plugin installed?
No. I don't. Oh, okay.
So we have a a a crew plugin
where that actually let a kube control plugin
that lets you bypass that whole thing. So
you'll see a picture of it here where,
you know,
you run kubectl get nodes. Okay. It's not
authenticated.
This was the first time I ever made
a GIF out of a video. I think
this took me about four hours.
But you see that pops open the the
browser window you log in and and similar
to, you know, if if you're working with
any of the cloud CLIs
that pop open
Nice. Or the the OU login. But the
the cool thing about that is is that
there's no preset configuration options
at all.
There's nothing to distribute because that that's one
of the hardest things to do in an
enterprise
is distribute things, keep it updated.
I've got a bank that's probably my largest
Kubernetes customer,
and
they've
held off on
just this, the OU login plug in for
almost two years now just because it's a
pain for them to go through the
submitting something to be distributed
across the bank. Mhmm. You know, it's gotta
get scanned. It's gotta get you know, there
has to be a deployment
plan. You know, there's a central repository. You
know, you can't just download stuff and run
it. You've gotta go and get the official
thing.
So we wanted to give you the option
to do both.
Now we
you know, it's it's quarter to two. So
I I have all the time in the
world.
Do you wanna try adding a cluster for
multi cluster? Yeah. Let's do it. Okay. Cool.
So grab your your
yep. Go right there. You got it.
So
what we did with multicluster.
So there are two ways you can do
multicluster with OpenUnison
depending on
your
level of comfort with Kubernetes.
You can do it where every cluster
gets its
this happens regardless. Every cluster always has its
own OpenUnison.
And the reason why we do that is
let's go back to we were talking about
silos. Right?
If
I have my own cluster
and I want to
add Argo CD to it and do SSO
into Argo CD,
I don't wanna have to go to you
as the cluster manager, as the Kubernetes team,
and say, please integrate my cluster.
I wanna integrate into my cluster's OpenUnison
so that I can do SSO.
And so everybody gets their own OpenUnison.
Now
you can either set up each OpenUnison to
go back to your main identity provider. So,
like, this would be basically repeating the process
we just did for every cluster,
which is a little painful. But if your
main Kubernetes goes to or your main cluster,
your control plane cluster goes down, it doesn't
take out everybody else. So it limits your
your blast radius.
The major downside to that is if you
don't own the connection
up to your identity provider,
that can be painful.
And and, again, silos and enterprise, the people
who own authentication
don't generally aren't the same people who own
your Kubernetes clusters. They're different people. They care
about different things, and they have a backlog
of people who want onboarding,
you know, from here to the other ocean.
So, you know, it doesn't matter which way
you go around.
So it it's a trade off of, you
know,
of blast radius versus flexibility.
I've seen a tendency to move towards
the flexibility side in enterprise
more and more because people are getting more
comfortable with with low downtime Kubernetes, maybe not
zero downtime because somebody's selling you zero downtime.
They're probably lying.
But, you know, low downtime Kubernetes,
you know, planned downtime Kubernetes.
And so this
now means that
I can now grant
authentication
to new clusters. I can automate onboarding new
clusters
whenever I want. And so that makes it
easier to automate. You know, we talked about
small clusters versus big clusters.
Well, if you do wanna go that small
cluster route or virtual clusters,
you can now have
every cluster has its own authentication
into that control plane,
and you can control it yourself. So it
gives you the best of both worlds.
So in order to do that,
you treat your control plane OpenUnison
as an identity provider.
So that means,
you you know, that work where we did
where there's a client secret and you've gotta
exchange that trust,
that's not rocket science, but it's manual task
that no one likes to do. Well,
everything's API enabled, so why don't we just
automate that? So that's what we did was
we want to make it so that you
enter as little information as possible.
So the the first thing you do is
you do this piece where you go back
to your main values YAML. So we're still
on the control plane.
And if you go down to the OpenUnison
section,
see where it says
well, you wanna get rid of it. But
Oh, alright. There's already a show portal org.
It's false. So you wanna change that to
true.
Alright. And then
go ahead and
save that, redeploy OpenUnison
using
the yep.
And notice you're not putting any of your
secrets. I am a professional. Oh, yeah. I
know how to copy and paste your documents.
I don't. So, you know, I assume no
one else does either.
So this is update in our the OpenUnison
deploy that we have in our control plane
cluster.
It's gonna add something to this this thing.
Right? So see where you now see there's
that little
bump
where it's got that little tree there? So
now it's breaking up the badges
so that's a little more organized. Because once
you start adding clusters
you know, you got a dozen clusters. You
don't wanna have 24 badges
all over the screen. It gets difficult to
organize.
Plus the other nice thing is you're probably
not gonna give access to everybody
to every cluster.
You know, usually certain clusters, only certain people
will have access to. This makes it a
little bit easier to organize that.
So
while that's updating, we can actually get started
on the next piece,
which is
there's a new OpenUnison values YAML.
And what's important about this particular file is
that it does not have
it it does not have
an authentication section
because we figured that out for you. We
already have all the information
from the control plane. So why ask you
to put in information
that
we already know,
you know, on our side. Mhmm.
So if you go ahead and you
start editing that
Alright. So I need the IP address for
cluster two.
Yep.
Okay. I can do this in the command
line.
Alright. So 2
and then
Yep. Beautiful. I can do that. Hold on.
Oh, you you got better Vim skills than
I do.
Dev.io.
Boom.
Alright.
Damn.
If I knew that, would have passed my
c k a d a lot more easier.
I'm assuming we don't need need to modify
anything else. Right? This is just
Yep. Everything else is good. Do we need
to point it to cluster one?
So so this is where the beauty of
of Kubernetes comes in. Right? So you're gonna
set up the
you're gonna
so you've downloaded
let me think about this. So the way
I typically do this is I don't use
Kubey myself.
So I create a single kube control file
with contexts to both. So what I'll do
is I'll take the Bootstrap contact
Bootstrap file,
and then I'll make that my main kube
config file. And then I'll log in to
my control plane,
run the run the onboarding command, you know,
that that
the kube control creation command, and that gives
me a unified
kube config file. So our control plane is
gonna reach out to the other clusters to
to So you you you wanna have your
your your control plane file and your
or your your bootstrap for your
satellite cluster.
Okay. And do the And then overlay 51
9 need to match? Like, the No. No.
No.
We do all the certificate exchange and everything.
Because, again, we know what those certs are,
so why bother asking you?
Okay. So what do I need to do
now? I need to
So you wanna be
pointing to your
satellite and install the dashboard.
That I can do.
Yep.
That part's easy. And so then the last
part is creating
the COOP config and then running the OU
control satellite install.
Alright. Okay. So OU control install satellite. This
is now cluster two dot YAML. So let
me Yep.
Did the other deployment finish?
It Almost.
Did it actually finish or did it fail?
It failed. Oh, there it goes. Yeah. Oh,
okay. That's fine. I think it was just
the webhook again.
Yeah.
Okay. So
this is going to be my
So that's gonna be your control plane
configuration,
and then the second one is gonna be
your satellite configuration.
Yeah. That's gonna be And we're using the
Go SDK,
so I don't know if that's gonna work.
Because we only I don't know.
Because doesn't Kubey just wrap?
All my configs are in different files, so
we're gonna have to merge.
Yeah. What I what you can do is
so this is how I do it. I
set kubeconfig
to the bootstrap for the satellite.
Mhmm.
And then I log in to my control
plane, get a token,
and in the same kubeconfig,
run that so that way I get a
merged configuration.
Okay.
So
let's jump back.
Sorry. I've made this really difficult now by
using Kube.
Well, it's it's it's
it's an interesting problem that I need to
take a note on because
one of the things that we're working on
is
simplifying this because we always wanna make it
easier.
So, you know, it's a good point. I
I tend not to use Koobie.
So,
you know, is there a way to make
it easier when somebody is using it?
Okay. So we're now using this.
Yeah. It could be config.
So now if you go to log in
to your control plane
and pick up a token
Oh, I just did that. Okay.
And then paste it in.
Alright. Shit. Okay.
Cool. Onto cluster two.
On my control plane, and I wanna grab
Run the kubectl command.
Uh-huh.
So now if you run k c t
x, you should have
more code control context.
So yeah. So you've got now two.
Perfect.
So now your
your
OpenUnison
one context is your control plane. OpenUnison two
is
Gotcha. Your satellite.
So that's what you're gonna use. Too many
steps ahead of me. That's what it was.
Yeah.
Alright. So we wanna do
open Rawkode or OpenUnison one.
Nope. Just OpenUnison dash one because you want
just the context.
And then
open OpenUnison dash two.
So now
if you look at your
values dot YAML,
we actually updated it for you.
So what we've done is we've created a
client secret inside of the control plane, big,
nasty, random monster,
so you don't have to think of it
yourself.
And now we're deploying OpenUnison as a satellite
directly into
your satellite cluster.
Yeah. I'll be able to look at it
in a minute. I also make things really
difficult for us on this session by always
using temp directories for everything that I don't
know the path to.
Yeah. That makes sense.
But Because I have a directory history, so
I never like to be in a real
directory when I do demos because then I
have all the commands in my in that.
Right. Yeah. No. That makes that makes sense.
So yeah. So now what we're just doing
is we're installing OpenUnison
the same way. It's just if when you
look at the values dot YAML
that you create that you created, you're gonna
see that it is
it now has an OIDC section.
And that OIDC section
points to
your control plane as your
identity provider. So can I see these satellite
clusters as custom resources on the control plane
cluster?
Not to the easiest way is to actually
do a helm list
in the OpenUnison
namespace.
And you'll see there it is, satellite dash
Kubernetes satellite three. So that is your satellite
cluster and all the resources associated with that
chart.
So it created
a
identity provider. It created a
like, if you do kubectl get applications
in the OpenUnison namespace on your control plane,
you'll see that there is a cluster IDP
Kubernetes satellite.
Yep. That's where we onboard all of your
satellites onto. Do a kubectl get trusts?
No. I don't think it's there yet.
Oh, no. It's just Okay. Now it might
be. Maybe not. Not yet.
Yeah. There are too many objects to keep
track of. But if you now go back
to OpenUnison,
See where you have that Kubernetes satellite? Now
if you click on it
and you go to the dashboard,
it's gonna make you click through a bunch
of stuff because we're using all self signed
certs.
And boom. Now you still have the same
problem with a little bell because of RBAC,
but the important thing is is you now
have a satellite
OpenUnison
deployed,
and you didn't have to do anything with
OpenID Connect or GitHub or anything else.
But I can just swap between these different
different
clusters like so. Exactly.
And then, you know, we haven't really talked
about other applications, but, you know, like Argo
or Grafana
or anything else. You can now integrate that
here. You know, you can you can integrate
it into your control plane
or into your
into your
satellite.
Now the other cool thing is
the OU control. If you click on, like,
click on Kube control's
satellite tokens
so this actually runs its own OpenUnison.
So you can go directly to this host
too if you wanna bypass it.
So you've got that option
as well.
So, like, the OU control command that I
was talking about, you know which hosts you
have access to. You just type in OU
control
dash dash host equals my OpenUnison,
pops up the browser, you log in, you
close. So you don't have to go through
this rigmarole.
And then, you know, of course, if you've
got, you know,
a CA that you wanna use, you can
use that instead of having to do the
self signed certificates.
You know, we we wanted to just make
it as easy as possible to get started.
This is really cool. I like this.
Thank you. So
what we haven't really talked about is so
we we we've we've done the authentication portal.
We haven't really talked about namespace as a
service.
Do you want to deploy namespace as a
service?
Well, I I don't know what namespace as
a service is. Do you wanna get me
the the pitch? Yeah. So
namespace as a service, the idea is you
can log in to a self-service portal like
this,
and there's a little button that'll say request
or there'll be a button here that says
new namespace.
Click on new namespace. I enter some information,
like what I want the namespace name to
be,
what
I can add additional attributes,
you know, for things like chargeback and labeling,
and then I hit submit. And then the
cluster owners say, yay or nay.
And then OpenUnison will actually provision that namespace.
It'll do a few things. It'll provision the
namespace.
It will provision the RBAC bindings.
If you want to use external groups so,
like, let's say you wanted to use
your GitHub teams to manage access,
it'll
map those for you.
And so at that point, you now have
a namespace,
and you can also customize the workflow to
add things like network policies, resource quotas, etcetera.
So now as a business owner,
I've been able to get a namespace without
running kubectl.
And as a cluster manager,
I've been able to create a namespace without
running kubectl.
So that that's the first part of it.
The second part of it is who has
access to it.
So
we allow you to do either internal or
external or both. And by that, I mean,
you can let OpenUnison have a set of
groups for you and manage it that way.
You can rely on an external identity provider
like GitHub or Active Directory and groups there,
or you can do both. And we find
folks that use this functionality,
they always start with, oh, I just wanna
use the enterprise groups.
And then they realize, oh, it's a lot
harder than we need when there's an emergency
to onboard someone,
and so we wanna use the internal groups
too.
And so what that then gives you is
the ability to do self-service to get access
to those namespaces
all without having to do
what you want? All without having to do
any kube control commands.
And then we keep an audit log of
everything that's happening. So, like, at KubeCon
twenty
Europe yeah. It was twenty twenty Europe. That
was the one that got delayed twice. Right?
Yep. It was all virtual.
I did a session on learning RBAC called
I can RBAC and so can you,
where I used OpenUnison
with Fairwind's RBAC manager
to let people create namespaces
without actually having to go through any approval
process,
where you created a team
which would provision the RBAC. Are you familiar
with what Fairwinds RBAC manager does? Yeah.
Okay. So for anybody who isn't, it lets
you do access management via labels inside of
namespaces.
Really great tool.
So you would request
instead of namespace, you would request a
I forget the name of the object, but
it's basically a Fairwinds RBAC object
that would define what labels
namespaces would have, and you would have access
to those namespaces.
And then at that point,
once that got approved and provisioned, you could
create all the namespaces you wanted
associated
with your Fairwinds object.
So as a business owner, I could create
all the namespaces I wanted.
And as long as I had access via
that Fairwinds object,
it would create the namespace and set the
appropriate labels.
So it's a really powerful tool. My favorite
thing that I'm working on right now
is
virtual cluster as a service, which is really
cool. So if if you're not familiar with
virtual clusters,
it's
it's essentially a k threes that runs inside
of your cluster, and it synchronizes objects
and gives you a smaller world view. So
you think you have your own cluster, but
in reality,
you're still running in a large multi tenant
cluster.
So
Loft, the folks that make vCluster,
recently released the cluster API
for provisioning of this. So what you can
actual what we have is
this way where where this portal I can
show it to you where when you request
a namespace, there's a little option. Do you
want a namespace or do you want a
v cluster? You pick v cluster.
We provision the v cluster.
We provision OpenUnison into it,
and we link it via SSO.
And now you have a v cluster ready
to go with all your RBAC bindings,
and
that's it.
Alright. Well, I
would love to get home from my kids'
bedtime. So I'm gonna share your screen.
Okay. Cool. Give us the d cluster demo
and we can take a look at it
because it sounds pretty awesome. And then Yeah.
We'll wrap this up because I reckon we
could talk about this stuff for for a
couple of Alright.
Can you see my screen?
Yes.
We can see your screen. Thank you. So
I'm gonna log in. Don't save. So I've
I've deployed a couple of these,
but I think I deleted them, to be
honest.
So
this this link
didn't exist. This request access link doesn't exist
in your OpenUnison.
Yep. And this badge, this new Kubernetes space
badge doesn't exist.
So first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna open up the dashboard,
make it a little easier to follow what's
going on because there's a lot of moving
pieces here.
So we got our dashboard up and running,
and I'm gonna go ahead. I'm going to
say create a new namespace.
So this is our namespace as a service.
It's multicluster.
So this has just a single cluster for
management.
And I'm gonna do test
Rawkode because I'm really original.
And I'm gonna choose v cluster and test.
So that's amid the request. Now I've gotten
an email that says, hey, Mark.
Somebody's requested.
Oh, cool.
And so this gives you the current roles.
We're we're in the midst of making this
a little bit better because there's just more
information you're gonna wanna have. Now some of
the fun things you can do here with
custom approvals
is you can do escalations.
So I'm not doing my job. It's been
a week. You know, escalate it to my
manager or escalate to someone else or automatically
close it.
We're also doing things around capacity management
where if you request the namespace
and there's a certain amount of open capacity,
just let it through. Don't bother requesting it
because we're tied into the cluster. We can
do all that fun stuff. I'm just gonna
go ahead and approve the request.
So
while that's going,
I'm gonna go ahead and show you the
reporting. Right? So we're keeping track
of all this stuff.
And when it comes time for the auditors
to come by,
you know, you can give them access. You
can generate the Excel spreadsheet.
All that stuff's being tracked. So let's come
to the dashboard.
And if we go to the
OpenUnison
namespace,
let me go check out pods.
See here. Did it launch?
Didn't.
Alright. So first question is, did I make
the appropriate
did I make the appropriate sacrifices
to the gods of live demos?
That's okay.
Sometimes this takes a little while.
Oh, wait. Actually, first, let me see here.
Test. Oh, this test raw code.
And okay. So it's actually deploying our virtual
cluster. That's right. First, it deploys the virtual
cluster, then it launches a
a helm chart that launches a job that
integrates it. So you can see it's actually
building out the dashboard for us.
And this is actually
our OpenUnison. So what's actually happening now, you're
seeing it in real time,
is we've created the virtual cluster. Now we're
integrating that virtual cluster into OpenUnison.
And so if we look at these pods,
we're actually looking at
our
our whatchamacallit? Our
virtual cluster being stood up.
And so this is a little bit of
a slow moment, but what's happening is behind
the scenes
is we wrote a custom hook into our
onboarding workflow
that uses the cluster API that Loft built
for v cluster to create the v cluster.
Once
and then we just wait for that v
cluster to to be done.
Once that v cluster is done, we then
return execution
to go ahead and kick off that job.
So now if I look at this, I'm
pretty sure
that's running. So
if I go to the OpenUnison
namespace,
I look at pods.
So this is still running.
So this should look familiar. Right?
So
this is that automated.
We we we we
took a
we took a pod, and we put kubectl,
v cluster,
and Helm in it. So that way, we
could automate all this stuff. So all that
pain you went through of setting a context,
we did that automatically with the vCluster.
Right. So now
see. Do I have access to it?
I don't. So I'm gonna go ahead and
log out and log back in.
So now I've got a new v cluster
dashboard.
Now
the dashboard actually doesn't really work too well
because v cluster by default doesn't deploy metrics.
So we're still working out the kinks here,
but you can see we we've got it
automated so you even see which dashboard you're
in. And then when you get a token
I didn't really think this through, did I?
Let's see if I can set this up
so that you can see what's going on
here.
I'm gonna make this the same size.
And then
if I switch my sharing
woah. That's cool.
How do I get out of this? There
we go. So I'm going to stop sharing,
and I'm gonna share
that. That makes it a little bit easier.
Can you see that now okay?
Can you drag the height down a tiny
bit
of your window?
Oh, this? Like that?
You're sharing just a single window. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. So if you just make it less
tall,
that that's it. Yeah. Go for it. Yeah.
So I'm right now logged in
to the v cluster
as the logged in user.
So
the the
the really nice thing about this is I'm
interacting as me.
Now if I went back and I I
don't wanna give everybody a headache by switching
Windows again. But if I go back and
I look at the Kubernetes audit logs,
it shows I'm logged in as Moseley to
the virtual cluster
all for free.
Nice.
It's all automated. So I'm actually working with
a customer. The end result of this is
something I call an ephemeral cluster
where the idea is going to be to
create a completely disposable cluster
that you never have to debug.
So that automation, in addition to the OpenUnison,
will deploy an Argo CD.
It'll deploy a GitHub instance,
link everything up for you
securely.
And
that way,
if you get to a point where the
cluster is irreparably broken, you can time box
and say we're gonna spend two hours trying
to fix this.
Okay. I give up.
Nuke it, but it rebuild itself from source.
That is very cool. I mean, that's not
just namespace as a service. That's an entire
cluster as a service. I really like what
Loft are doing with v cluster and being
able to
hook that in with this, like, resource request
process through OpenUnison
to get people access to stuff. It's just
it's really awesome. Really, really cool work. And
in fact, Rawkode on the chat is doing
the same.
Icing on the cake for a great tool.
And he's right. Like, everything we've seen today.
It's one of those things that, you know
I I spend up a lot of clusters.
I work with a lot of clusters,
security is the thing that I just always
hide and stray from because it's hard.
So having tools like this where we can
make them the first thing we deploy and
get that identity and access problem just done
and dusted out
is awesome. So I I mean Awesome. Thank
you. I appreciate that.
That means a lot.
Sweet. So
any last words? Anything you wanna share before
we finish up today? I think we're gonna
have to schedule a part two and do
something else together. I I think we can
come up with pretty Pretty cool.
I I've got some interesting ideas or something
we can build together. Oh, yeah. Definitely, man.
I wanna hear them.
My I I I I I think everybody's
ideas are far better than mine. So I
really wanna hear what you know, I I
I love being able to to take other
people's ideas and make them reality. So yeah.
Absolutely.
Hey. I'm really easy to get a hold
of at MLBIM
on Twitter.
Same thing in the Kubernetes Slack. I'm always
there.
Feel free to hit me up with a
question. I love answering questions. I love helping
people out.
Again, I'm gonna do the the shameless self
promotion.
Amazon.
Amazon dot co dot u k. Where is
it? There we go. Amazon.co.uk.
Yeah. It's it's up there.
You know, I I will say that I
have been
absolutely intimidated
by the idea of going on cluster date.
It's I see what people pull off, and
I'm like, yeah. That makes perfect sense. It
never would have dawned on me to do
that.
You know? And I just I I would
love to, but then people might realize that
I'm I'm I'm I'm a sham.
I'm I'm more worried that we could deploy
an open to the cluster,
deploy an approach to cluster and save the
cluster and set up the local KubeConflict to
point to that. Like, that's what I'm scared
of. But
that that would be a lot of fun.
What I gotta do is I gotta see
if I can drag my partner in crime
on the book, Scott Sarovich,
on with me
because he's
like,
when it comes to to living with these
massive headaches of debugging clusters, he knows it
even better than I do, much better than
I do.
But
yeah. But I've had a blast.
Thank you so much for
doing this and having me on. I'm having
a lot of fun, and I look forward
to having fun doing more stuff.
Well, I really appreciate you taking the time
today to kinda walk us through OpenUnison. It's
a super powerful tool. It solves a whole
lot bunch of problems, and I hope that
a lot of people find this very useful.
So thank you very much, Mark, for joining
me.
I'll reach out to you afterwards. Like I
said, I've got ideas. I'm gonna talk to
you. But until then Definitely. Have wonderful weekend,
and I'll catch you soon.
You too, David. Adios.
Adios.